anyone p brown here at mark Walton we're
at Gamescom 2014 we just got out of
sony's press conference and well there
are a lot of games shown in fact the
most at games come ever for sony so they
say said they say mark i know you were
really impressed i came out feeling like
we've seen a lot of these games before
and there wasn't a whole lot of new
games shown at least to an extent that
got me very interested but I want to
hear how you feel cuz you were very
positive well you know at the end of the
day like you look at the the sort of the
line up games what I want to see in
sunny was though he's a games I got that
and with Sony games like compared to the
microsoft stuff especially I think you
do get a wider variety of stuff right
there was some really interesting things
now when we kicked off an infamous like
we knew about that anyway but then you
know then you get into blood-borne and
that's looking really cool there like a
hole in D section you know it's just for
me personally it was a bunch of games
that looked interesting fun to play and
really different from just a string of
shoes but were there any shooters Martin
in maybe you can see I'm destiny destiny
1886 I think would apply as a shooter
usually said that they show that the
show and they're really couching it in
this hole I'm Nikola Tesla and I'm doing
this it's really great you know being as
this pioneer of electricity evil that
game looks sexy as hell like if nothing
else you know I played that game before
and it is very much third-person shooter
II sort of stuff but it looks
you done some amazing work with a vision
for my game so yeah I will not argue
that these games didn't look great but I
think the feeling I had coming out of
this is that everything was so briefing
bag but if you can existing it to me the
most were tearaway and until dawn yeah
until dawn was a playstation 4 u horror
based game that we haven't seen for a
long time that has now been confirmed
for PlayStation 4 they've been teasing
it for a while and it basically tells
the tale of eight friends who are at a
cabin and are being hunted by a
homicidal psychopath for lack of a
better description yeah and he came
loose good it looks scary but the cuts
were so hard and you know it was like
three seconds of gameplay apiece yeah
I'm intrigued and I really want to know
more I get you with that I mean you know
I want to know more about these game
certainly when the conference started it
was a little odd because there's a
trailer there's another trailer and then
another trailer where light is anyone
coming out to speak at this thing or is
it just like trailers the whole thing
but we could get some port I mean like
Ninja Theory so they announced their
game their brand new game yeah he'll win
hell blade that's looking for an
interesting we went to a talk at GDC
today we're to me the head this year was
talking about my father saw his sort of
mid-tier triple-a sort of game theory
right but that's looking real cool so we
did get some announcements there was a
new house mark game as well which looks
very weird alienation it's very much
like I got a Robotron inspired
twin-stick shooter but setting it in a
way that's he a reminiscent of Diablo in
a sense but also
Helldivers get away it makes it that
sort of sci-fi element with these old
monsters you kind of firing all over the
place very much one of house mark jones
they take an old game and to repurpose
it for the my regeneration I'm gonna
story cured gameplay driven experience
it looks great then we had a lot of the
bigger experiences like destiny and you
know far cry 4 they have these elements
that are unique to the PlayStation 4
experience yeah which are valuable I
mean people who care about these games a
lot want that exclusive content and
Sony's got that for them but I'm really
waiting to see what comes out of games
column over the next few days yeah I
mean we know I mean we're gonna see some
really really good games behind closed
doors which will be writing about for
you guys and we'll be checking those out
what I mean hate Kojima you like you
like Metal Gear Solid all right I love
the whole year I love middle gear but
they're leaning so hard on the cardboard
box mechanic and then leaving so hard on
the sexy woman the boobies the ideal
that Oh soldiers are going to be
distracted by a woman painted on the
side of a cardboard box for a game that
is leading so hard on a serious tone
yeah that took me out of the experience
I need to see how they're going to
justify that I know those games are
meant to have a duty element but the
type of that's all they showcase I'm
kind of confused sure sure I mean so
over wolfie then sony gamescom 2014 yay
nay or I don't know I don't know I
really don't know now I think for me
it's more VA I think you know I wanted
to see some real interest
I got him and I'm really looking forward
seeing what they got for the rest of the
show and obviously what we can bring you
guys back home yeah so in the next few
days team the game spot we're gonna have
information on all of these games so you
know from our call tonight thanks for
joining us and stay tuned for the next
few days